hey guys welcome to the Reuben report
according to the metadata I'm Dave Rubin
and I've got Jen Hoffman and Sean
Hollenbach with me and let's get right
to it
okay the NSA scandal continues and
depending on what channel you're
watching this is either the most
horrific overreach of government ever or
they're protecting us and our civil
liberties are not at jeopardy I want to
start though with Fox News they just are
an endless cacophony of hilarity Sean
Hannity here is some compilation of what
Sean Hannity thought about the NSA and
spying and that sort of thing when Bush
was president that's George W Bush and
here's what he thinks about it now that
Obama's president so take a look and
then we're gonna break it down is it
right to say that for example on issues
involving national security be at the
NSA surveillance program the data mining
program the Patriot Act Guantanamo Bay
that Democrats are weak on issues
involving national security when our
techniques are working we've got the NSA
program here we've got the Patriot Act
program here you know in light of this
how close this was I it's staggering to
me that were even debating the use of
these techniques in this country even at
this time
big brother is monitoring your every
move whether it be online or on the
telephone let's talk about why this
story why is this important to you
number one this is America and as
law-abiding American citizens you have a
right to privacy number two these
actions by the Obama administration are
clear very clear violation of the Fourth
Amendment which prohibits unreasonable
search and seizure number three the
Constitution it is our rule of law if we
do not respect and honor the
Constitution then anarchy and tyranny
will there follow okay so that is
exactly why I wanted to do this show and
why I started this whole thing because
the media is actually worse than the
government he loved it when it was for
Bush he hates it now that Obama is doing
the exact same thing
is this just like the height of
hypocrisy and can we expect anything
better so we just like the most I rollin
ridiculous character now he's surpassed
O'Reilly like at least O'Reilly usually
will retain some semblance of you know
this is what I'm saying and I and I
stick with it if he changes his mind he
said that changes his mind yeah
Kennedy's out of his mind and just will
go with whatever he thinks you know the
most right faction or whatever the
market research people at Fox tell him
and I think at the time when Bush was
president they were just like no you
know 9/11 just happened and patriot act
and we have to support George Bush and
then they know they did their market
research which was just googling do you
hate Obama check the yes box for watches
Fox when they were like oh now this is
the worst thing that's ever happened so
it's we expect it it's stupid it's
obvious but the problem is it's not
obvious to the viewers of Fox so
speaking of the viewers do you think
when the regular viewers the people that
have been watching this guy and it's
millions and millions of people that are
watching tonight so you think that the
regular viewer that digs this guy is
going wait a minute I know that he
didn't believe that a couple of years
ago or they just don't care well my
dad's missing teeth and doesn't care so
I don't think you he doesn't do any
research at all like using care hit me
but he'll believe whatever they say and
okay he's big that's all he watches this
fox news right love you dad but you're
an idiot but um but what I think is so
funny is that Hannity is sort of the
bizarro liberal whatever the Liberals
think he thinks the exact opposite just
to just to please their audience base
it's like I hate the way Obama choose we
should stop chewing no no I don't know
it's just Obama could do anything and
they'll just say it's wrong yeah do you
guys I'm so I'm so on this idea that
this is actually worse now because of
the media then because of the governor
because I feel like no one ever trusts
the government really well like if we
can't even trust the media and look
MSNBC is almost as bad on the left as
Fox is on the right in the middle just
getting it wrong is falling from the sky
exactly to get ratings yeah which they
don't get ironically yeah that's the
funny part I mean Fox is crushing them
all together and MSNBC is in the middle
and and CNN's getting slaughtered but if
we can't trust that we're gonna ever
turn and who do you trust who do you
trust in the media first of all news
excuse a little bit older excuse to
people that depend on the television
news that depend on their news anchors
and that believe that these people are
telling him the truth people that were
brought up to believe that when you're
listening to a news program like your
father my mother similar my mother's
almost 70 years old she watches Fox News
and what they say is gospel to her
because she believes these are the
authorities telling her the truth yeah I
think younger generation understands
that a that there's companies that own
these people there's people like Rupert
Murdoch there's corporations there's
advertising dollars there's all these
different reasons why certain large
media entities have reasons to kind of
skew a story a certain way or make a
story bigger and then I think you know
younger people kind of just turned the
internet more and not that's always more
helpful yeah [ __ ] on the Internet
are you saying not everything on the
internet is absolutely true yeah I'm but
I think Eddie I think they're holding on
to an older audience and I think that's
what it is and I think older people tend
to believe what they're told from an
authority because that's kind of just
the way you were raised because they're
closer to death and judgment when you
were younger you know you didn't you
know really question authority as much
of course some people did but I think it
speaks that why your father and my
mother and another generation of people
watch Fox News because they're like nope
whatever you say is true yeah I just
wonder what happened to getting in llego
I trust him and he was he was MTV News
you're really going yeah but is there
really wait I don't even who that is oh
we're like CNN or something yeah I'm
gonna Google her when I get home but is
there someone in the news really I mean
thank you I know it's me but besides me
is there someone in the news that you
watch and actually feel like this person
is like intellectually honest and really
makiura - I said Miku which I was like
so much just like the most random
reporting of early report he just
[ __ ] like whatever they're like just
say it first
exactly
for some reason Anderson Cooper has this
hold I feel like I'm a lot of people I
know we're we're like we trust coops and
I don't know why it's just his hair it's
just the hair and the hair and that
perfect skin I know yeah I want to marry
him all right Jeff but I like also like
Lisa Ling who I think is a really honest
reporter and I feel like she tells the
full story yeah and she's very
trustworthy because her sister was
kidnapped
she's only trustworthy everyone was like
well her sister was kidnapped trust her
because she looks very emotional when
Oprah had her on and they were like you
saved your sister nestling had the one
tear and then they booked her for every
show for the rest of her life I'm kind
of like Lisa Ling I don't trust you I
think you're - no I think she's my
famous cuz they kidnapped her sister she
was also she was on the view the view
who's on the in high school they had
this TV channel and she was one of the
one of the anchors oh you weren't out
yeah you were yeah I didn't do my
research know what you guys are talking
about you guys were anchors on a high
school TV show oh you mean the big
closed-circuit ones like everywhere
whatever that didn't exist how that
exists when she was she older than me
this is getting weird so final thing on
this is should we when I was looking at
this story like I really wanted to do
this because I think it's important that
people really see it side by side like
the one opinion and the other pinyon and
really just show it to everybody so they
see the [ __ ] but do you guys ever
think that we should just not cover
stories like this because it's like I
have a policy on this show and on
Twitter I don't talk about the
Kardashians because I think you that's
how you take the power away should we be
doing that kind of thing when it comes
to something like Hannity and just let
it be ignored and be free you have to
call it out so obvious and so ridiculous
and even though it's preaching to the
choir because I'm sure a lot of people
that watch you and I'm gonna be watching
things on YouTube aren't necessarily a
fox news viewer it's so blatant it's
like
mostly blatant like how it to be yeah
those clips side-by-side are just so
outrageously blatant and gross and to
show you what that news channel is all
about that you're like how can you not
show it yeah yeah yeah so final thought
as an artist and someone that puts out
you know comedy and your thoughts I
think do you think there's ever a moment
that you've had where you've put out
something that you said one way and then
cruelly just absolutely said the other
thing you know just again yes yes we all
want yeah we all want the retweet
retweet this like this thumbs up